thousands demanding their states ease
restrictions so they can get back to
work
governor's now unveiling plans to lift
lockdown orders in Florida some Beach is
reopened with social distancing
guidelines Texas governor Greg Abbott
says he plans to reopen State Parks on
Monday and reopen retail businesses for
pickup delivery and mail orders next
Friday
interesting developments there and so we
want to go ahead and bring in
congressman Dan Crenshaw remember the
House Homeland Security and former Navy
SEAL author of fortitude American
resilience in the era of outraged
Congress ring - warning - yup
tell me about what's happening down
there in Texas well we're doing what I
think we should be doing which is a
staged reopening you mentioned exactly
what governor Abbott has declared and
we'll have more announcements of what
will be open by April 27th another thing
I would add to that list which is really
important is allowing more surgeries and
procedures to take place in our
hospitals our hospitals are empty right
now
and doctors are putting off important
surgeries these aren't nose jobs we're
talking about my own father had to had
that trouble getting in to get a heart
stent and placed you know so this is
some common-sense stuff that needs to
happen I hope Texas can lead the way and
demonstrate how this needs to go for the
rest of the country and congressman
you're right my mom is a director of
nursing at a surgery center in
Pennsylvania and you know they are not
even doing elective surgeries and a lot
of elective surgeries though even though
it has that term elective they are still
very important to people and their their
health you know it that's the utmost
importance to them right now yeah 100%
you know there's another public health
concern when we start to close hospitals
and when we when we allowed the economy
to continue to falter and we have to
keep talking about that that has to be
part of the balanced discussion on how
we live side by side with kovat 19 what
with in an open economy we can take risk
mitigation measures while getting back
to some sense of normalcy that's what
we're doing here in Texas I think the
whole country's can can follow suit
congressman we're in a moment of
federalism people are waking up to
looking at their state governments and
their governors and the way they view
the world in new jersey phil murphy said
you know that the Bill of Rights he
wasn't thinking about it when he was
making these calls what's your message
to governor's as they
make these decisions as it pertains to
the first rights of American citizens
now first of all take a civics class you
should always be looking at the Bill of
Rights and also understand understand
which laws are respectable and which
ones aren't people will not follow and
respect laws that are not respectable
themselves use some common sense okay
you know you saw in Michigan where
they're sectioning off gardening
supplies in an open store I mean come on
this is this is nonsense and of course
people aren't going to respect that
these governors have to think through
what is the connection to stopping the
spread with their new law it's a very
simple question but they're not thinking
through it and voters should hold them
accountable for that well congressman
your lieutenant governor Dan Patrick is
holding you members of Congress
accountable saying that you need to get
back to work and possibly take a pay cut
here's what Patrick had to say to Laura
Ingram I'm really tired of Nancy Pelosi
and Congress because they're you know
what they're not hurt by this they're at
home they're doing nothing it's time for
them to get back to work and quite
frankly I think they need to take a half
pay cuts in Texas we make our senators
and our House members and myself make
$600 a month we work 50 hours a week we
have the tenth largest economy we meet
every year we're volunteer public
servants it's time for Congress to take
a pay cut so they feel some of this pain
that people at home are feeling because
Congress isn't feeling any pain the
people and the small businesses are now
get back to work and cut your pay and
show that you're with us Dan your
thoughts on that you agree he's half
right we do need to get back to work and
start and get this PPP program
absolutely up and running I would remind
my friend Dan that not all of us have
$24,000 refrigerators like Nancy Pelosi
I so I understand where he's coming from
he's absolutely right we've got to get
back to work not all members of Congress
came into Congress with a bunch of
buddies so just let me remind of that
let's go ahead and talk about your new
bill that would allow Americans to sue
China over koban 19 tell us details
about this all right so as we see
increasing evidence that the Chinese
authorities the Chinese Communist Party
hid this virus do
liberally you know a loud domestic
travel a restricted domestic travel in
China but allowed international travel
from Wuhan disappeared these scientists
and doctors who blew the whistle
wouldn't allow our journalists in
wouldn't allow samples of the virus to
be sure there's an increasing an amount
of evidence that shows that they are
culpable okay so what can we do about
that
well when Americans are wronged what do
we do we sue somebody well let's let
Americans to the Chinese government so
this bill would simply change the the
foreign sovereign immunity Act so that
we can actually do that in our courts
now we would do it in a select few
courts so that it doesn't become
overwhelming and we think this would be
a great way for the American people to
seek damages against the Chinese
government I think it's a it's a great
idea what what other things should our
government be doing as we have this
unfortunate moment of exposure of the
evil of this communist regime what more
can we do to stare them down take them
down yeah well there's a lot of things
and I think there's a lot of political
will to do that it just it just becomes
a technical discussion you know another
bill that I thought I proposed would
would would not allow Chinese officials
who engaged in propaganda during the
pandemic to be allowed into the United
Nations in New York City and we have to
start dusting off some other old Chinese
policies to talking about protecting our
intellectual property from Chinese theft
you know just protecting our supply
chains bringing those back home for for
core for core manufacturing that we'd
absolutely need in this country you know
this is a conversation that was
happening long before this crisis but I
think this crisis shows us that that we
need to move forward with a lot of these
policies quickly go ahead good Joe no I
was just gonna say you know how
confident are you that that we here in
the United States are able to get all of
the answers that we need from China as
to how this all started as to how it was
able to escape and penetrate the entire
world do you feel confident we'll get
the answers we need well I feel
confident that we did in an
investigation to do that Senator Holly
congresswoman Lee Stefanik have put
legislation forward that would that
would require an international
investigation and of course the Chinese
Communist Party
is always going to lie and try to try to
cover for themselves that goes without
saying but that doesn't mean we can't
seek out the truth you know there's
there are a lot of oppressed people in
China and I bet they want that word to
get out and the truth or tea is coming
out that's why senator cotton and I he C
he proposed this in the Senate side this
is my bill on the on the house side
that's why we did this we want Americans
to feel like they have a voice and and
that our justice system can be can be
used to to actually deliver justice for
us congressman well I got to get to this
because it's out there and many of us
saw it or clips of it you were on with
Bill more last night and yet some
comments making the rounds tell us what
happened well a lot happened of course
they make it all about Donald Trump
listen the the the narrative I've seen
of late is this that that President
Trump has blood on his hands that they
didn't do anything that they denied the
whole thing and that's just not
factually correct I've created videos on
this we've been very vocal I put this
out in podcast we need to get the truth
out to the American people and when I
was on Bill's show he thought the same
thing so I just had to stop him and say
look like at every point in your
timeline there are other things
happening that you're leaving out and we
just point those things out you know
I like chatting with Bill because it's
just a good debate frankly and I feel
it's necessary for for conservatives to
go on shows like that and talk about
these things we also talked about
elections and waiting in lines and I'd
you know correct the record on that
there's so many misconceptions out there
that the left just believes and they
just repeat it over and over again and
so they just start to think that those
things are true so it's up to us to
actually say hey let's let's confront
this directly this isn't true here's the
context here's the actual facts and you
know I love doing it it was fun good
stuff yeah I can't wait to check out the
entire thing you talked about going on
the offense though not letting
narratives that are false
continue you wrote an op-ed called that
it was entitled this tactical retreat
from kovat 19 made sense now let's go
back on offense and mobilize what's the
most critical thing
right now that we should do to go on
offense yeah well what I mean by that is
we have to have we have to live with
this truth that we simply have to open
up our economy and live side by side
with the wrists of kovat 19 now we can
do this safely all right there is not
this binary choice between between
Perpetual lockdown and actually letting
people die that that's not the choice
okay that we can risk mitigate and you
do it along three factors ramping up
testing which we are doing rapidly
ramping up hospital capacity which we
have done rapidly you know that's a
ventilator production PPE production
making sure that we have sections of
hospitals that are still designated for
kovat 19 patients and third public
education the public is well educated at
this point I think people can take some
personal responsibility wear a cloth
mask get back to work maintain six-foot
social distancing it's a new normal but
we can make this happen every single
business every single restaurant can
live with them this new normal we have
to start trusting the American people
and the American people have to start
empowering themselves with the proper
tools to risk mitigate I think that's
what that looks like that's what offense
looks like well set trusting the
American people that's been the premise
of our experiment the entire time
Congress and Dan Crenshaw thank you so
much for your insight this morning we
appreciate thank you thank you